Community Ambulance is contracted to be
present at all Raiders home games
because as we saw in Cincinnati you just
never know Victoria Saha joins us from
Henderson to give
to give when you're at a football game
you're often busy with the excitement
that's surrounding it you don't always
get to see the prop work that goes on
behind the scenes to help keep our
players safe and as we saw Monday night
the EMS that was on ground in Cincinnati
could have potentially helped save Demar
Hamlin's life it's a moment that has
shaken up the NFL Buffalo Bills player
Demar Hamlin falls to the ground after
being hit in the chest tens of million
people just played witness to what
sudden Cardiac Arrest looks like Glenn
Simpson is the senior director of
Community Ambulance his team is
contracted with the Las Vegas Raiders to
be present at all home games being able
to watch that really kind of check the
box as far as a lot of the emergency
procedures that we go through that we
train on a not only an annual basis with
the NFL Simpson's eyes were glued to the
screen as this is a scenario they always
prepare for that moment can be any
moment any time a player goes down you
never know what it what it might be and
how the emergency action plan went as
planned that night Simpson tells us
before kickoff they gather with both
teams to go over safety plans part of
what initially is going to happen to
that player is they're going to be
hooked up to the cardiac monitor that
then tells us what Rhythm that the the
athlete is in from there then we'll make
determinations as to whether if the
patient's in a shockable rhythm before
Hamlin was taken by ambulance news
outlets on scene report he was given CPR
on site for several minutes in most
situations where you haven't out of
Hospital cardiac arrest people don't
survive and so it's you know our message
to people is that by standard CPR saves
lives and as we mentioned those first
few moments were critical as CPR was
performed on Hamlet coming up in the
next half hour Community Ambulance shows
us how they administer it Victoria Saha
eight news now Victoria thank you now
some have noted the ambulance was on the
field for some time before taking Hamlin
away Simpson says ideally the patient
will be stable before putting them in a
moving vehicle